new in theaters this weekend Gemini man
The Addams Family and jexy what will you
see this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
I know why as good as you he is you 25
years ago they made you from me they
chose me because there's never been
anybody like me we have to end this
right now
you have all of his gifts without his
painting
made a person out of another person
then you sent me to kill him while
searching for answers on a hit he
performed assassin Henry Brogan is
targeted by an assassin who seems to be
his perfect match and knows his every
move when Henry finally meets the
assassin face-to-face he realizes it's a
younger clone version of himself Gemini
man uses some impressive face tracking
technology that probably wasn't
available when it was conceived in 1997
and the film is directed by Angley
screenplay writer of tortilla soo no
that's not a good example ha director of
Hulk from 2003 this movie is for you if
you love Will Smith blockbuster movies
you're excited to see what they can do
with that face tech or you finally have
a movie you can bring your clone to
right buddy come on out oh hey head of
sub sponsors we need that clone effect
money
they're creepy they're kooky they're so
on and so forth
The Addams Family hits theaters this
weekend when the Klan makes a move to
New Jersey they find themselves as
fish-out-of-water in a current day of
cell phones and Karen's Wednesday
struggles to fit into assimilation
middle school while the rest of the
family prepares for a family reunion
that includes husband it played by Snoop
Dogg the family is voiced by an all-star
cast Oscar Isaac Charlize Theron Chloe
grace Moretz Finn wolfhard Nick Kroll
Bette Midler and a bunch more someone
can post in the comments thank you kind
stranger this movie is for you if you're
looking for a fun family movie you're a
fan of any of the previous takes on The
Addams Family or you hate fish and water
take a chance and try something new
she's so cute no I did not this case you
ready to go yeah let's go would you mind
not bringing your phone Otis [ __ ]
and lastly jexy comes out this weekend
when Phil gets a new smartphone with a
personal assistant feature named jack
see it starts getting a little too
involved in his life in fact it starts
to get creepy embarrassing him insulting
him and trying to thwart his attempt to
date a girl he just met Shh raise your
hand if you've had worse relationships
than that this movies for you if you're
looking for an r-rated comedy this
weekend you like the comedy of Adam
Devine or you're scared of your phone
new I'm it goes no not like that
that is your weekend ticket what will
you see and come back next week for the
return of two beloved series is beloved
two beloved series
[Music]